for more than 84 years New York City
skyline has been dominated by one famous
skyscraper the Empire State Building
soaring 1,454 feet above midtown
Manhattan it took just 13 months and 7
million man-hours to complete the
Empire's Art Deco spires serves as a
beacon to native New Yorkers visitors
and quite literally to broadcasters it's
technology still supports all the major
television and FM radio stations in the
New York metropolitan market more than
four million people a year marvel at the
view from its 86th floor or if you're
famous and lucky enough to be invited
you can brave the climb to the secret
bird's nest one of the highest points in
the Big Apple on a clear day you can see
up to 80 miles spanning five different
states standing on two acres of prime
real estate the Empire is also one of
the world's largest office buildings
which is why it's also worth so much
money the firm that owns the Empire
State Building raised a King Kong size
929 million dollars in an IPO last year
the second biggest ever for a u.s. real
estate investment trust